the deal's not a deal until the money is
the check has been cashed and cleared in
the bank
have you ever pitched a completed film
to netflix
oh yeah yeah
definitely
um
well the first one was completed i mean
i pitched it before but then i had to
pitch it after to get it sold the second
one was a completed film kiss and cry
that that was pitched after the fact
um i pitched
do you want me them
i mean
um you've already asked it so yeah i
pitched another one that they said no to
which i think is my best film ever but
uh they didn't think so and they said no
and they didn't tell you why
didn't
no wasn't a fit for the audience even if
they did honestly i honestly don't even
hear why like because
i feel like it's just being polite
whatever it is like if you say it's not
a fit for your audience then
their audience is so big everything's a
fit for their audience
they own the entire world audience so
i mean if they say it's not an
entertaining movie then
truthfully i guess my ego is too big to
believe that because i've done so many
screenings with it i know it's
entertaining to audiences i mean i've
been in so many festivals with the movie
and i've watched real audiences not
friendly audiences people who know me
like you know complete strangers watch
and critique the movie so i know it's an
entertaining movie so when somebody says
it's not an entertaining movie then i
say i respectfully disagree but you get
to say it because i because you own the
audience and i don't
but that's okay that's their prerogative
it's their business
when we played that one little game
before which i really liked where you
said
what's your movie and now i need you to
fill a hundred seats from people that
are not friends and families co-workers
whatever
do you ever
run out by your students and do it and
do they
well no it's because it really gets you
to think critically and and it makes the
stakes a little higher to really really
dig in and say okay who would i put into
those seats
and what do they say like what are some
of the ideas that these students have
well it depends on the movie
you know like uh you know i don't want
to get into too many details because you
know i don't want wanna
it's not fair to my students whatever
like like one of the groups did pulp
fiction okay you know so um
they went into a lot of detail of who
that movie goal would be now there's
probably tons of research on the
internet that they probably could have
borrowed from i don't know but they
thought about you know
what age group what demographic
you know where
what that type of movie would attract
that type of thing so
you know and
they
gave me reasons of why they thought that
was the people and it doesn't matter
again whether it's right or wrong
because there aren't no writer there
aren't right and wrong answers
um
it's about the reasons why you do the
critical thinking you do so they say you
know they could say that's for 12 year
old girls and as long as they tell me
why they think that and it's rational
then they'll get a good mark now i
totally disagree that movie is obviously
not for 12 year old girls because
there's so much violence and swearing
and all that kind of stuff but they
wouldn't say that obviously but they
might say you know males uh
50 to 70 and i might say well you know
it's probably males you know 30 to 50.
but you know tell me why you think 50 to
70 and they might say because
we think that those males are more
mature and have more time and would like
the violence better or something like
that as long as the reasoning is good
it's about the critical thinking because
it's constantly changing as i said right
so i want to create critical thinkers
who who can be creative and just
be rational now they'll work in teams
ultimately when they're in the working
world and
and it's good to have different input
and and different ideas
you know and as long as you're not crazy
and delusional you know and coming as
long as you it's about thinking about it
that's what that's what learning is
about is about
thinking critically about something and
and trying to understand it best you can
it's not about
right and wrong necessarily in this this
isn't math there's not a right answer
and a wrong answer this is about how you
come to it
was there a waiting period after you
pitched netflix the first time
yeah um
you mean until until i got an answer
i had the six weeks or so something like
that they had to circulate the movie
internally a bit and think about it a
bit
that i can't remember exactly but it
wasn't it wasn't a long like it wasn't
more than that maybe maybe four weeks
something like that it was relatively
soon god you know you're sitting on pins
and needles the whole time you're so
anxious
but um you know they do
fears for you know they have a million
things to look at and they you know they
have to get opinions of few people
when netflix said yes to you what did
that yes mean
it meant that i just became a real
filmmaker
[Laughter]
now it meant like
it's surreal at first to be honest with
you it's like holy smokes but first of
all
you gotta understand i am so skeptical
about everything because i've been in
business by myself for so long
that i've seen so many deals fall apart
so the truth is and i hate to say it the
truth is and i do this with everything
so people
if anybody who's ever worked for me
knows what i'm about to say
it's like
the deal's not a deal until the money is
the check has been cashed and cleared in
the bank so even though you have a deal
in writing even though it's all signed
sealed delivered you've delivered the
movie when the money comes and it clears
then it's a deal
and everybody says like why can't you
just celebrate they said yes you have a
contract here it is they're taking
delivery i said yeah
but i've seen lots of deals there where
they falls apart at the end the very end
even though it's what are you gonna do
you're gonna assume netflix you're a
little like lowly filmmaker and you're
gonna take them you know and you'll
probably settle or something like that
if the deal were to fall through
but i kind of wait until the very end so
as much as i was thrilled and happy
it wasn't done until it was paid for
do you think that's a good matter to go
by do you think too many people are
trusting and get their hopes up and so
that's when you said you'd been through
so much and so much rejection yeah it
seasoned you in a way that
you're you're more up to close any gaps
that yeah it's not a good way to be i
mean it's good to be able to really
celebrate and everything like that but
but the word you use is right it's
seasoned that comes with experience i
mean
generally when you've done being in it
enough time that's any business not just
the film business but you know when
you've done enough times and you've seen
sort of what the scenarios are and how
it plays out
i just don't want to set myself up for
disappointment and i
underst you know especially when it's
new territory like it wouldn't happen
now with netflix now i've got enough
experience and i know who they are and
they're big enough company everything
like that but back then it was the first
deal i didn't know what to expect and
i'd
seen a deal go sour a really good deal
that i had done before a few years
earlier went sour at the 11th hour like
it was a done deal and it went sour and
i was in a position to you know sue but
i pursuing is not a good route to take
because
it's costly and you don't want to ruin a
relationship you know so so i guess i'm
a little jaded no i'm a lot jaded
but for good reason i'm i am have a lot
of experience i'm super seasoned and you
get jaded when you're seasoned
but i do still allow myself to celebrate
when the time comes but
i choose when the time is
how many guaranteed ways are there for a
filmmaker to get their film to netflix
guaranteed ways
that's a kind of a loaded question
almost like it's
it's like it's like leading a witness
there's no guarantees
you're talking netflix i mean the only
guarantee is i mean there's two
guarantees one is you're making the
movie for netflix because they hired you
it's a netflix original and they hired
you to make the movie that's guaranteed
because they own the movie and they
hired you or two is they pre-buy the
movie from you based on an idea or a
license which highly highly highly is
unlikely those are the two guarantees
otherwise
you know you do it you hope for the best
i mean but both of those first scenarios
are generally
netflix original movies where it's not
really your movie you're just making it
for them
what are some of the non-guaranteed ways
to get on netflix that just
shot in the dark
well the first non-guaranteed way is
make a movie make it really really good
create a lot of awareness for it
you know not necessarily give it away on
youtube for free but do something that
gets a lot of maybe social media
activity
something that you do special or maybe
release or something like that
that's probably the best non-guaranteed
way because it will put you in a league
where you'll be able to get their
attention because now
two things have happened one is you've
made a good movie it's finished so they
don't you're not pitching them on an
idea you're pitching them on a finished
film
and two is you've also gotten an
audience which they want audience their
business is not about content their
business is audience they're in the
business of signing subscribers remember
that
the way they subsidize sign subscribers
is to create good content now they're
also in the content business now so
someday they're the value of their
content library is going to be worth a
ton of money it probably already is
right now but the major asset is
subscribers and they create good content
to get subscribers so if you can show to
them that you already have like a ton of
interest
and maybe some of those people will
become subscribers if they put their
movie your movie on their service
that's a gigantic plus for them
you know like if you're dealing with say
a niche audience right
and they don't maybe have that niche
audience or think that they could sign
another you know 20 30 40 50 000
subscribers based on that movie
they're going to be all over that
so that's the best non-guaranteed way to
do it but it's you know you're making a
movie it's super risky and they also
might say no and they may never see the
movie like how do you get it to them
right you gotta have an agent or a
manager or somebody or the best way as i
said last time is to go through an
existing distributor who already has a
relationship with them
but the best way to get that distributor
is to have that audience to have that
awareness to have that notoriety already
it's not just it's not this is where the
narrative is different it's not good
enough anymore to say hey i have a great
movie it's not good enough even to have
laurels from you know low end film
festivals i mean if you have the
audience choice award from toronto or
can yeah you're good but who gets that
one movie you know a year and probably
you know so chances are you're not going
to have that what's good enough is
you've done some marketing and created a
lot of awareness and all of a sudden
the distributor
slash who's going to talk to netflix can
say
look how much interest we already have
we're not only bringing a movie we're
bringing an audience with it
seems like a lot of authors are doing
that as well so it's very similar
they don't get signed sometimes by these
big publishing houses until they've
proven that they have a big social media
following right i could be wrong about
that but but the good news is for here's
the good news for indie filmmakers if
we're going to take one piece of good
news is
the because of the digital world you can
actually do that now you can actually
reach out to the audience yourself now
it's a super crowded marketplace because
they're inundated with all kinds of
stuff but you know
10 20 years ago you could not connect
with the world
with individuals around the world now
you can
um like i say it's just hard to get
through all the clutter but at least the
it exists the technology exists to do it
so if you got a message and you know how
to work it and manage it and you know
maybe create this niche area where you
can get it out there at least it's
available to do it
whereas before you had to do generic
television advertising or or print
advertising whatever and spend a ton of
money and not even know if you're
connecting with your audience
is that something that your
students are concerned with how do they
kind of rise above the noise because
there's so much we're inundated with
every day yeah i don't think young
people are as concerned about that
because they're part of the noise they
are the noise right
i see it as noise because i'm used to
other stuff but but they're they are the
noise right
so they're well way more connected than
i am way more up to speed on all the
platforms um you know it's constantly
changing obviously
i'm not hip you know i tell you the
funniest thing the the the one
compliment my oldest son paid to me
so the back-ended compliment was
dad
the only thing cool about you
is that you actually know that you're
not cool
i took it as a compliment okay no that
was a total compliment you know it took
so much pressure off me like i didn't
want to have to chase around and try to
you know pretend that i knew all these
platforms and that i was on instagram
and doing this and all that kind of
stuff
i i don't want to do tick tock videos i
just don't want to do that stuff i i
recognize that it is super important and
that there's a gigantic world out there
and it's
very big for marketing i recognize it
totally
but at my age and who i am i'm not i'm
not going to do that i'm going to hire
people or can you know i'm going to
circle myself with people who
who are good at it who want to do it who
enjoy it more than i do so i'm not
saying it's not important because it
totally is i'm just saying i know who i
am and i don't want to try to be some
cool instagram you know
person or i don't want to be a
youtube influencer
i guess maybe through these videos i'm a
little bit but yeah i think you all no
no but what i'm saying is like i don't
have to do these silly weekly videos
that you know are going to do crazy
stuff to make me i don't even want to do
weekly webcasts or podcasts i it's just
i'm not interested
so that's what he meant at least you
know who you are and you're not
interested in that now having said that
the young people are super interested in
all that kind of stuff and it's great
because the tools and listen there's a
lot of people who might be in my class
or you know who are in that generation
who are going to change the world right
they're going to come up with new
technologies or they're going to work in
companies that apply these technologies
and and do special things that that are
going to you know change the way people
think and
and new habits and new ways
i mean look what's gone on in the last
year
with the whole black lives matter and
the whole i mean these are social
movements that change the way people
think and the whole world
and so
that's great you know that these are
that's the generation that's gonna
embrace that and take and take charge
and hopefully we'll do you know do good
with it
that's great that you have so many sort
of ears and eyes that are able to
tell you different things whether it's
students or your sons and and
you can kind of see them in action with
whatever
on whatever platform yeah you know
because some people don't and
you know there's so many things that are
changing and evolving oh this platform's
not not no one's using this now so you
know it's funny for my students so when
we were doing the marketing part and i
was talking about social media i
literally said to them at the beginning
of that lecture i said
what i'm about to tell you is what i
know but i'm pretty darn certain
hopefully that i'm right that you know
way more than i do so i'm just going to
go through the motions and in your
papers i'm going to learn more from you
from in this section then you're going
to learn from me
because i know that you are active on
these platforms and i'm not now we
talked about buying facebook ads and
stuff like that which is you know i
don't do it i hire people to do that so
i understand how it all works and how to
target and do that kind of thing and
they don't didn't know about some of
that stuff
but they're going to be way better at it
than i am and it's way more savvy
because that's who they are
each deal that you've received on
netflix has it improved each time it's
three films yes it has yeah
that might be a combination of a couple
things one is
i got lucky
it could be that i just got lucky that
they were paying more each time
two is maybe the films are better but i
don't think they're necessarily better
in terms of the production quality
um but i think maybe it's because they
see that my films are getting an
audience and that may be worth a bit
more
so they being fair really fair because
they control that side you know you can
have a little bit of a discussion but
for the most part they say here's
where you're going to fit in
and if you say no they got 50 other
films waiting in line to fit in so
there's a little bit of room wiggle room
but not a heck of a lot but at least if
they say you're this is what the film is
worth and and they recognize that the
value is there because they have an
audience and
they know it because they had an
audience for the previous one so
so it's similar audiences so that's
maybe why they've been fair like that
have you made any pitches to netflix
during the pandemic
yeah
yeah of course i have
i mean you know the pandemic does i mean
i can't shoot anything um but i i did
pitch them on the movie i want to shoot
and uh
you know they're interested but but i i
told them i'm not shooting during the
pandemic so maybe that's my bad but
i think everybody understands that right
but it was another scenario where it
looks good sounds good we like division
we like the style of movies you make and
everything like that but you're going to
need to make it and make sure you make
it well
it's still good
do i have a tracker with them yeah do i
have relationships yeah
it's still a new adventure every time
though
you know because they're i'm a little
tiny
speck of dust in in their universe and i
know it um you know maybe i shouldn't
belittle myself that much but um so i
don't take for granted i you know you
got to deliver and it's got to be good
and it's got to resonate and by the way
i still plan on doing all that audience
awareness stuff that i talked about
even more so now now that i'm really
aware of it and real niche
and lots and lots of marketing before it
goes to them if they're going to take it
so that i can bring audience to them i
want to be able to say the major pitches
to them is like yeah here's the story
and it's a good movie and it's going to
resonate but the major pitches look at
the audience that i think i'm going to
be able to bring to you because of all
the marketing i've done
what constitutes niche in the eyes of a
of a platform like netflix or hulu or
disney
um it's it's specific like you know i
tend to make family movies and primarily
sports dramas so this one's also a
sports drama based on a true person you
know true uh
like a true true life story
um so niche would be
sort of what the sport is
who this the person is that we're
talking about if there's some sort of
like community around that person that
would be interesting
you know
to use a very very big example i mean
obviously this is way bigger than what
i'm talking about but so netflix
recently released the tiger woods um you
know
two-part series and it wasn't it was
some filmmaker made it about tiger woods
and it was really really well done as a
matter of i can't believe how well done
it was based on the fact that he didn't
he wasn't part of it they
like it wasn't you know an authorized
biopic they did it based on footage they
got anyways i i love golf and so so look
at the niches there i mean first of all
you've got the celebrity of tiger woods
in the sports world
you've got the whole golf world because
pretty well anybody who's a golfer is
going to watch that so there's you know
you deal with the pga the professional
golf association and you know there's
lots of associations you know like i
remember the southern california golf
association everybody heard about it
through that so we all got it very niche
target marketing to the golf world
obviously to the overall sports world
and then you know the general stuff is
to the celebrity world because he's a
major celebrity you know in his own
right even though he's an athlete but
you know he's
probably more well-known in the world
than any actor is or you know way up
there with them
so but you know they say that's an
extreme example because you're talking
like probably the most well-known
athlete in the world
but the niche is the golf thing right
and so even if it wasn't tiger if it was
some unknown golfer
he still could have gone into the golf
world because generally like i guarantee
i know a lot more golfers than you know
on the pga tour i think so um so if they
had used somebody who wasn't the
notoriety of tiger but you know somebody
who was i was interested in as a golfer
they could target me and that alone
would be and you know and then it's also
demographics you know generally a lot of
people who golf are
more so male than female but you know it
goes both ways but you know they
there's ways to target that sure and
that's a good demographic because that's
someone that's going to have disposable
income
to spend on things
even if you're not putting it on a
platform where it's just whatever
fifteen dollars a month and that might
be a good place to start getting someone
to yeah i would imagine i mean look at
netflix has such a big audience that i
always assume everybody's got netflix
but they don't but i always assume
everybody does but you know i would
imagine that you know there's there were
a lot of golfers who maybe don't have a
netflix subscription that maybe did sign
up for a netflix subscription just to
watch that special and it was well it
was really well done so they probably
got their money's worth now will they
stay subscribers i don't know that's up
to netflix to start to profile them and
feed them other golf stuff or whatever
stuff you know netflix is good at that
right suggested yeah films yeah